hello everyone
welcome back i'm rebecca finley and i am
very pleased to be
moderating and leading this final panel
of the day on ai policy bonjour
one note please remember you can join
into the conversation on social media by
tagging cfar news
on twitter with the hashtag ai can
and we are going to end the panel with
your questions
and so please submit your prep your
questions through
the zoom q a function at the bottom of
the screen and i will try to get to them
at the end of the panel the focus of
this session
is on ai and policy and as minister
champang
affirmed so clearly in his remarks this
morning
the government of canada has committed
to developing
and implementing policies that promote
trust
in a digital world and keep pace with
the rapid
technological development of ai
we know for example about the launch of
the digital charter in may of 2019
and then the recent legislation proposed
through bill c-11 the digital charter
implementation act in november of 2020
alongside all sorts of international
efforts including the global partnership
on ai
and as the minister kindly mentioned
this morning cfar's ai and society
program
part of the pan-canadian ai strategy
this program supports working groups
on a range of topics related to the
social political and economic impacts of
ai
and most recently with the generous
partnership of idrc
focusing on a call for ai governance
solutions
in low to middle income countries canada
is fortunate we have a rich community of
experts
and advocates committed to charting a
path to responsible ai governance
we have offices of information and
privacy commissioners across the country
ai and social science researchers and
legal experts
as well as human rights and civil
society organizations taking up the
cause
and we are very lucky because we have
some of those leaders with us today on
this panel
so i am going to introduce them and as i
do please take a moment to
share in the chat the top three things
that come to mind for you
about ai policy in canada
so please join me in welcoming four um
remarkable individuals who are going to
join today's discussion
first we have goal news farnadi gulnush
is a canada
cfar ai chair a member of mila
and an assistant professor at heck
monreal she is a leader in algorithmic
fairness and machine learning and
decision making causality
and interpretability great to have you
with us
also patricia cosim patricia is
ontario's information
and privacy commissioner with a wealth
of knowledge and privacy and access law
and extensive experience in the public
private and health sectors
i for one think we are very lucky to
have you in ontario
patricia so thanks so much for joining
us then we have deborah raji debra is a
researcher
and a mozilla fellow in 2020 she was
named one of the top
innovators under 35 by mit
technology review for her research on
racial and gender bias and facial
recognition systems
deborah great to have you with us thank
you so much
and finally we have jacques rajat
jacques is a lawyer and a leader in
international development
who is currently the interim executive
director of the international center of
expertise in montreal for the
advancement of ai
for the global partnership on ai thanks
so much jacques
so let's get underway i would really
welcome
hearing from the four of you on sort of
with a very broad
question just to reflect briefly for us
to get started
in sort of three minutes ish perhaps
respond to the question
what do you think canada is doing well
with respect to ai policy and where do
you think
we can improve and commissioner patricia
why don't we start with you
thank you rebecca and thank you for the
invitation to be here i'm
very honored uh to be joining this panel
of wonderful
wonderful colleagues whom i've just had
the pleasure of meeting it's always
wonderful to meet new faces and new
people in this space
and so thank you for that opportunity so
um in terms of what canada is doing well
in terms of ai leadership i'm going to
speak about privacy
aspects of that ai leadership in
particular and i will say i would say
that
from my perspective i think canada is
quite an influential actor on the
international stage
uh punching way above its weight
relatively speaking
in terms of privacy leadership and to be
clear i'm not talking about legal
instruments
which are sorely lagging behind but i'm
talking about concrete policy actions
uh that canada has spearheaded and there
are several reasons for this
first um as you alluded to rebecca where
we have a federal system of course here
in canada which means we have 14
jurisdictions
each with its own commissioner or data
protection regulator
and as we say in french
this certainly strengthens our capacity
our involvement
and our collective voice on the
international stage and in particular
our role in the global privacy assembly
which just this year for instance this
past year
adopted a resolution which our office
co-sponsored
on accountability uh responsible
accountability in
ai second we've had a really strong
and steady cadre of commissioners who by
their own individual personalities
interests and priorities have taken a
very proactive stance in the
international
arena and i'm thinking here for instance
of the influential concept of privacy by
design that was minted by my
predecessor here in ontario and has
become an integral component of the
eu gdpr among other
modern privacy regimes around the world
the previous federal commissioner has
had a very influential role in updating
the oecd guidelines
on privacy and security and really
was instrumental in building the
foundations for international
enforcement cooperation we're seeing
made possible today
between data protection authorities
around the globe the current federal uh
private commission has been
made very significant behind the scenes
contributions to strengthening the
governance process
the governance structure of the global
uh privacy assembly
and one of our former commissioners in
canada from bc
has gone on to take the leadership of
the uk
information commissioner's office which
is probably the largest
dpa or data projection authority in the
world
third i'd say uh given the absence of an
overarching federal privacy law in the
u.s at least in the private sector
this has really allowed canada to take a
highly credible persuasive leadership
role visa vr counterparts
internationally
without being overshadowed by our
neighbors to the south
for a change and fourth i think we've
built a very strong privacy research
capacity
in canada uh thanks to some amazing
research programs you mentioned rebecca
and to name
i think some of the some of them um
would include you know the large-scale
social science projects we've seen uh
dedicated to privacy
funded by shirk the consumer interest
research program funded by
industry innovation science and economic
development
privacy research funded by the office of
the privacy commissioner
and not to mention the interdisciplinary
research
programs prompted by cihr through its
ethics and knowledge translation
programs
genome canada's integrated jails
programs and of course
cfar's ai and society programs so many
of these opportunities have helped
our canadian privacy researchers gain
visibility on the international stage
uh and uh have some very significant
influence
uh so the this is uh of course
uh as i said paul you know concrete
policy
action and uh while our actions have
been louder than words
i think it's high time for our words to
catch up
and i'm talking specifically here about
the need to modernize
canada's privacy statutes but my three
minutes are up so i'll leave you in
suspense
and i'm going to talk a little bit more
about that later on in the panel
great thank you thank you patricia
and uh i love uh i love to think about
the words and the power of words and
uh the need for that and when we think
about what we're doing today uh in terms
of bringing these communities together
so thanks so much
deborah would you like to take a moment
to reflect on on that question for us
um yeah for sure um i i think i'm i'm
sort of
probably going to take a little bit of a
broader a broader lens to things
um in terms of to start off things that
i think canada is doing
very well and is very impressive is just
the agile policy development
especially with um the algorithmic
impact assessments and that effort
um incredibly at the department of
treasury i believe it
incredibly impressive how sort of
quickly
um that group was able to iterate on
that idea um
and how um you know that effort has
really stood
as an example for a lot of other
countries a lot of the work i do is in
the u.s and
in the american context and even in that
context it's really
um uh sort of a gold standard in terms
of
quickly iterating on um you know
documentation practice for policy
purposes
um and and doing that you know at a pace
that's not typical of policy development
in general so
um yeah very impressed with the
algorithmic impact assessment effort and
how quickly that was able to
um be piloted and how quickly it was
able to iterate
um and also connecting that with
different stakeholders in different ways
to really make that effective
um so yeah that's definitely something i
think um canada is doing very well
also um patricia already mentioned this
but i think the privacy by design effort
is also
quite impressive um i do a lot of work
in facial recognition and that work has
been incredibly influential in terms of
the policy development in that space
um you know a lot of the standards for
data storage and data distribution
is sort of derived from ideas of that
work so
um i also agree that privacy by design
work in canada has been
incredibly influential and incredibly um
effective uh in terms of um
i guess things that are sort of
opportunities
um or things that um canada
you know might be might uh
i guess benefit from paying more
attention to um you know one that comes
to mind immediately is this
challenge of disclosure so and this is
not a canadian specific thing but
um you know at the municipal level at
the provincial level at the federal
level
um it can be very difficult for anyone
you know a journalist
a researcher a regulator a member of the
public
to understand you know to the answer to
two questions one question being
if their data is being collected and how
it's being collected or used as part of
some kind of algorithmic process and
then two
what kind of algorithmic process is
being used as part of
uh you know a governmental bureaucratic
process and given that you know
um canada as as other countries
you know um has a bunch of public
institutions
that require transparency on these
issues
it's become incredibly challenging for
researchers even to to get a sense of
how different departments or
institutions
public institutions even are making use
of algorithms to make very consequential
decisions about people's lives
so as an example of something i can
think of you know the toronto police was
recently discovered to be using
clearview ai
facial recognition a facial recognition
tool that's very invasive
um and it was it was revealed as part of
uh
you know a journalist looking into the
clearview ai
vendor and it wasn't anything that was
disclosed by
toronto police to the public or um you
know
even uh to any other sort of
accountability board
so there's a lot of challenges with
disclosure and with open and transparent
communication around
when an algorithm is being used and if
it affects you and if it's using your
data and things like that
and i think that's a huge challenge that
canada also has to face as well
um and then i will say the other sort of
uh
potential challenge that canadians will
probably
need to encounter with respect to policy
making is also
really having open and honest
conversations around
anti-racism and some of the issues with
you know
with respect to um you know the
the societal dynamics that contribute to
some of the injustice
perpetuated by these algorithms um
that's something that
in the u.s just due to the weight of
their history
it's sort of a conversation that flows a
little bit easier and is and people are
a little bit more informed about it
whereas i find um sometimes in canada it
can be challenging to
allow the conversation to get to that
point with respect to algorithmic
deployment and how that connects to
to to the way that algorithms are
designed and deployed um so yeah that's
what i would say would maybe be
a couple challenges to look forward to
in addition to the stuff that
uh canada is doing very well at thank
you so much
yes much much much more work to be done
uh on on both of those fronts so thank
you so much deborah
um cool news do you want to speak a
little bit to what you think
what's working well where you think
there could be some improvements
uh sure uh first i want to actually
thank you again for inviting me out to
this panel it's a pleasure to be here
and also
get to know all these people um
i i want to also mention one thing that
deborah also mentioned that
about the ai the impact
assessment algorithm assessment that is
happening in canada it's
the very impressive work that has been
done
but um i don't want to um repeat the
same thing as she said so i'm
going to actually mention something
which is kind of personal to me that i'm
very proud of
that actually uh i'm i'm considering
myself as an international researcher i
i worked in europe in
china and different institutes in the us
and the reason that actually i
i moved to canada was the ai policy
about bringing talents international
talents to canada
so there are so many fundings and i'm so
proud of it that there are so many
fundings for international times to come
to canada and actually make this
this ecosystem very attractive for
researchers to come because
they can come and actually work with
other talents as well
and specifically for the problems that i
am interested in is algorithmic
discrimination
we actually need uh international
people to come and think about the
solutions so this is
the place that i see uh so many
advantages of like uh there are even
advantages to international people to
come to canada for this and i think
that's one of the reasons that canada
can be
uh he is actually the leader but can be
one of the the biggest leader of the ai
technology um and the changes that i
want to also see is also related to this
because
um for the fields uh this um fairness
is by nature is interdisciplinary and as
you can see from the panel
we are talking about it is also from
different backgrounds because the
problem uh
needs uh people coming from different um
background to think about the solutions
uh one of the things about the ai
is that most of the the research is
happening uh at the conferences
so we have big conferences in ai like in
europe's and iclear etc
that are happening and because uh canada
is one of the biggest
uh ai ecosystem we are actually uh
having these conferences uh happening in
canada so for example news happened
in canada for many years but one of the
issues that i see
is that we should allow people to come
to these conferences because we want to
have the solutions to be from the
researchers from around the world we
cannot actually bring all of them to
come and work and leave in canada but we
can actually help them to come to these
conferences and
we can think about the solutions
together so one of the problems that i
see
is the problem with the visa the the
issue that we have with the visa so i
think
we can actually make some changes to uh
ease
the path uh to bring more people to
canada
thank you coalition and uh your comments
just thinking about it from an
international
you know researchers attraction and also
from conferences
um are just a perfect segue jacques into
into your role
uh at the international center of
excellence and the global partnership on
ai so
why don't you join us now and give us
your thoughts on on the question
before us yes thank you very much
rebecca and thank you also for the
opportunity to
join this this panel and be able to
introduce at least a very newer
initiative on a global basis which is
called gp the global partnership on ai
um i might i'm i'm sure i'm not the
youngest on the panel but i'm the
the newest one in the ai center because
as you mentioned before i come off from
a legal background
and international legal development that
that's very much
linked to the mission of the gp also and
you know i'll add comments to what ganus
just said
i think what's important to understand
first in terms of the
mission of the gpa it's not directly
focused on developing ai policy because
we have the privilege of having
as a partner the oecd as part of the gpa
and that's where the secretary of the gp
is situated but we are actually
at both end of the policy making first
you know
the mission of the gpa is to move from
theory to practice so we are developing
solution or experimenting potential
solution that will eventually
inform a policymaker and once those
policies have been adopted then we are
also at the other end trying to develop
business models
so that we will be able to implement
that uh the way that this has been
done and in terms of talking about the
the leadership of canada uh
for those who are not aware uh the
global partnership on the ai
is initially an initiative of canada and
france
started you know through a transition
the g7
presidency and i think it's uh it's
it's another great illustration of how
canada is taking a leadership position
on the adoption of responsibility i mean
everybody is aware of the declaration of
montreal had
resonated quite a lot on the
international scene so i think that
canada has a lot of credibility
and the the gpa is one more example of
how
we we in the our commitment to make a
strong contribution to the development
of the responsible
ai in terms of the specific
elements of the mission i think i would
like to link to the comments on the
international side i think that the
mission of the gp is not only to
ensure the promotion of the adoption of
responsible ai but to making sure
that it is done for the benefit of all
and more specifically in collaboration
and taking into consideration
the interest of emerging and developing
countries
so part of the mission of gp will be to
make sure that we are inclusive of the
voice of the developing and
the development the developing country
but we as a senior announce maybe i'll
spend just
10 seconds explaining what the center of
expertise was the abbreviation of the
uh is senior we are actually supporting
some of the expert group and one of them
being the responsible uh working group
um through their work to make sure they
have all the back office
and the proper support to be able to
deliver on their ambitions
and to deliver the impact as well of the
global partnership but part of what we
do also will be
to incorporate within our own team
international researcher what
comes from the developing countries so
we have been in discussion
uh over the last few months with various
governments
institution in canada to make sure we
have the proper financial support to do
that but that will be quite
i will assume one of the important
contributions also of the
senior to the positioning and of the gp
so i think that you know we'll continue
that conversation there's so much more
to
talk about the global partnership and
the role of senior within the ai
canadian ai ecosystem but i think it's
it's an illustration of our leadership
it's linked from before and after the
policy making so it's very much part of
a continuum
of implementation um and i can answer
more questions about specific work that
we will be focusing on over the coming
year
thank you jacques and i know we'll get
some questions in the q a for more
information about some of those areas so
thanks we'll um
we'll get into that uh later in the
panel thank you all um i think that
really helps to set the stage for some
of the questions that i think as a group
we
we would like to dive into a little bit
and one of the things that i found
useful
in thinking about ai and ai policy is to
really
understand specific use cases or
specific sectors to really understand
what regulatory regimes might already be
in place but also what the policy
challenges might be
so why don't we start with one of those
let's dig into the question of facial
recognition or surveillance technologies
a little bit it's clearly
top of mind we we saw it last week in
terms of
the events in in washington that's very
controversial
there are all sorts of initiatives
underway from all sorts of different
policy perspectives
so i think the question i'd be
interested is what do you think
policies and policy makers need to
understand
what is it about this particular
technology that is problematic
and uh what if any guidance uh would you
give them as they
as they start to think about uh this
technology moving forward
and deborah why don't why don't we start
with you uh yeah sure
my favorite topic um yeah i think um
there's a lot of uh really important
things that policymakers need to
understand about facial recognition
something that i start off with is that
it is um
you know often grouped in with other
biometric tools
such as fingerprinting and and other
forms of sort of
being able to track humans and surveil
them using their biometric information
but there's a couple interesting
differences with facial recognition
so for one thing um facial recognition
uh almost requires no interaction so my
you know i can i don't upload my
fingerprint
until so onto social media and
i need to interact with a particular
device in order for my fingerprint to be
you know uploaded somewhere whereas with
facial recognition
we're very casual um with the way that
we
handle our face data we um treat it
differently than we do
other biometrics we're much less careful
and thus you can find someone's face
quite easily
and that can be included in any kind of
database um
and also as i'm walking through the
street you know a facial recognition
camera can capture me and it doesn't
necessarily have to notify me that i'm
now
you know captured and and my image
processed so there's a lot of
um challenges with respect to the lack
of direct interaction with facial
recognition tools that makes consent
very very challenging
um the other thing about facial
recognition is that um
starting in about 2014 with the deep
face
model um that was developed by facebook
uh deep learning
has been sort of the primary method of
of training models for facial
recognition and that means that
there's this enormous data requirement
in order for modern day facial
recognition tools to work effectively
uh what this means is that there's
pretty much databases of you know
millions of faces required in order to
train a really effective model to detect
particular
attributes or to you know a database
that is much larger than
um you know what you might need for
other sort of biometric tools using
other types of methods so
um as a technology it is quite
particular there are
characteristics of facial recognition
that position it to be especially
harmful and and challenging and
dangerous um and with respect to sort of
the policy
directions that i hope people take with
facial recognition
um you know one direction that we saw um
i was
i i used to be a fellow at the ai now
institute in new york university and
um a lot of the work that happened in
that space was um
around disclosure like i had mentioned
before just understanding
when facial recognition is being used
and enforcing a requirement where
if my face is included in a database uh
that's then analyzed or if my face
uh if my face is captured in a way um
that you know i'm not aware of you know
how do i get notified if
the nypd or another sort of policing
um group such as like i mentioned
toronto police was caught using
clearview ai so if
there's a institution that affects me um
you know how can i be included in the
process of you know
asserting my rights and i'm being even
notified that
you know my police department is using
facial recognition
so uh the simple question of disclosure
was something that had to be really
fought for
um in new york what that ended up being
was the post act
which was uh pretty much an effort to
force nypd to disclose when they were
what kind of surveillance technology
that they were using um so i think
that's an
undervalued policy strategy is to just
encourage transparency and communication
with the general public about
how an algorithm is being used and when
it's being used um and then
outside of that something that's also
not very well considered or
often ignored is um this idea of
performance and that that's been a lot
of my work has been
auditing these technologies for
performance on different demographic
groups
so we've already seen in the u.s you
know at least two or three cases of
individuals with darker skin tone being
misidentified
by facial recognition tools and having
their lives really
uh negatively impacted as a result um
and then i guess the like very final
thing i'll say is
um and uh this is sort of
the the next wave of policy
interventions that we saw
um after the audit work really became
public
um was a move for restriction so you
know there's particular
institutions like i mentioned police
departments as a good candidate
um but also you know uh there's been a
great work by the
um the citizen lab at university of
toronto that's done great work into the
use of facial recognition and
immigration processes and things like
that
so there's a lot of cases where perhaps
facial recognition is a tool that should
not be used ever
so um a lot of proposals for moratoriums
and bans
for particular individuals or
institutions
use of facial recognition in a
particular context that's deemed
you know too high stakes or two um too
sensitive
for that kind of technology to be used
um so yeah i think i think those are
like
three policy directions that i i often
um um speak about
um that i hope i hope canada definitely
embraces moving forward
thank you so much others who'd like to
comment patricia yeah i just uh that
that was
excellent thank you deborah i i wanted
to just add a little bit of a postscript
to
um the story about clear view ai and
and bring and comment a little bit on
the specific use case that you
uh presented rebecca um as
uh some of you may know um and and
deborah alluded to this uh it came to
light
the the the assistance that clearview ai
was providing to police services across
um canada came to light and it led to an
investigation
that is being conducted by the federal
commissioner along with quebec
bc and alberta are holding or conducting
a joint investigation interestingly
clear of uai
um pulled back
and uh ceased providing its services in
canada but the investigation is ongoing
because of
the importance of result of producing a
report
uh given the uh the stakes for for
canadians privacy so it'll be very
interesting to watch
i just want to say it's not the first
investigation on this specific use case
if you recall remember there were the
vancouver riots of
2011 following the stanley cup loss and
on the evening of that game there were
riots and many
fans rioting in the streets of downtown
vancouver had taken photos
and uploaded those to websites facebook
pages etc
and the police ensued with an
investigation that
included the collection of thousands of
these images
and the insurance corporation of british
columbia had
developed a frt system originally
developed for reducing fraudulent
acquisition and use of driver's licenses
as part of the insurance process and
they
offered to assist the police with the
use of this technology
and they had no compulsion to do so
there was no subpoena no warrant
or court order and it led to an
investigation by the information and
privacy commissioner of bc
and this was more than a decade ago and
what was interesting there
was you know one of the key issues that
the commissioner raised was the shift in
use
from a uh technology that had been
developed for the use of
um detecting fraudulent use of driver's
licenses
uh to actually investigating criminal
behavior uh post uh
riot without any knowledge or consent of
the individuals let alone any adequate
notice to citizens that this was being
done
um and so uh i just wanted to point that
out because that is an interesting use
case here in canada
more than a decade ago and the
commissioner had this to say about
uh about the use of this technology
without judicial authorization saying
judicial oversight is necessary to
ensure that any use
any change in use of this magnitude is
proportional to the public good
served by the infringement on privacy
rights of citizens
so there's a lot of empathy and sympathy
for the use of frt
in the context in which we saw that you
know the um
the riots in in the capital uh but i
think
there are also compelling reasons to
make sure that the
guard rails and uh and the you know
respective human rights and civil rights
are are protected in the process
thank you patricia maybe i'll move on to
the
to another question um because i think
both deborah and patricia your your your
comments and advice with regard to
facial recognition and surveillance
technologies really
speaks to data and the way in which ai
and ai systems like deep learning use
data
and the requirement of
governments and for companies to
understand
how that data is used and how it is used
differently when we think about in terms
of
ai systems so i really would be
interested maybe beginning with you
going
to dig into the question of what is it
that you really think that policy makers
need to know about
how ai systems use data differently
than other big data or data analytics
programming um and what should they be
considering when they think about the
use of ai
in terms of either products and services
to citizens or
private sector products and services to
to customers
uh i want to also mention something
about like the applications that we
discussed the face recognition it's not
the
the only application that we see uh that
discrimination is happening
uh so uh currently like uh ai
tools are becoming part of the modern
society so we are
like people are using it in different
scenarios every day
even the first recognition is just not
harmful when you are using it in law
enforcement and policing you can
actually use it in like
when people are coming to the door and
recognizing their face and open the door
the simple scenario as that it could be
discriminatory right
so um the issue is coming like partially
coming from a data
because um we are living in the era of
big data we have access to a large
amount of data sets so
from the social networks we have uh from
the mobile data we have sensors
etc and also we have easy to use tools
ai tools at the moment and the
combination of these two
means that we are creating different
applications different domains that
people are using
without really considering the
consequences of like these kind of
applications
and now we have seen uh like many
negative impacts of
those cases and the issue is that like
people are
or the companies are uh using this kind
of tools are not really aware of
like the data that we are using so they
are not looking at the data
and the breakdown of the data with
respect to different
subgroups so we have discrimination uh
partially coming from the fact that we
don't have the
representation of the population in the
data when we are using these kind of
tools for
the general population so we have like
one group that
the model is trained based on it and we
are applying to
all the groups in the society so that's
one of the issues that we can see but
uh i want to mention like discrimination
is not just because of the data so
models can
learn those kind of behaviors from a
data because of the stereotypes because
of the historical discrimination
and can actually amplify it so it's not
just learning it and doing the same
thing it can actually amplify it but
unfortunately i should say that like the
way that these kind of
models are designed they could actually
introduce biases as well
so it's not the fact that like it's if
you are cleaning the data if you don't
have any issue with the data the model
itself is going to be clean
uh so we have to consider that
discrimination can happen at the world
side and that's why we need the
solutions
with respect to that um i also wanted to
uh
mention about um that
the issue about aia aiatix is a kind of
a vague term
the problem is that fairness by
definition is interdisciplinary and also
subjective so in different domains we
have to actually define what does it
mean
that is discriminatory and we do have
law against discrimination of course
but the issue is that it's designed uh
to be vague
uh so it's uh it allow for different
interpretations
um but when we are coming to the case of
ai
as a researcher as a computer scientist
you actually need a definition which is
deterministic
and that's why this kind of
interpretation of coming from the legal
document
into the ai system is kind of hard so
we know we have issues with data we know
we have issues with ar tools
with respect to discrimination but
coming up with the solution for that is
going to be very hard
because of it is very subjective we have
to define it for
different discipline different
stakeholders what does it mean that it's
fair or not
and that's a hard uh problem to solve
but it doesn't necessarily mean that we
cannot solve it
because um the issue that we are facing
is
the issue of today and if you are not
finding the solution even a good
solution not a perfect solution
today we are actually facing the
systematic discrimination which is
far worse than the discrimination that
we had before the society
uh we are dealing with uh the the harm
that is
going to be systematic uh and we have to
actually deal with it today
thank you uh would others like to
comment on uh
on those issues that gonch has raised
before we move into a q a with the
audience
maybe just very briefly if you allow me
rebecca
just just to uh connect maybe to the
international context the one that you
know i'm
i'm living in uh through the gp and in
the seminar
but i think that those buyers that have
been referred to
um also you know with especially when we
talk about you know developing or
emerging countries
we predict you know that a lot of those
when they implement or try to implement
some of those technology processes you
know in in developing countries
uh the the level of bias you know is
is the risk of bias is increased because
of
the fact that there was a lack of input
data in that process so that's that's
one element
the other element also which is one that
that could have an influence is the
the difference of the cultural
environment in which you know some of
those technologies are being implemented
and the implication that it might have
on the culture or the perception it
might have
from the cultural point of view also and
i think that when the
gp was designed the idea is that first
in terms of having as many voices as
possible represented at the table it's a
multi-sectoral so we have private sector
civil society as well
as scientists and academics who are at
the table so that all of the point of
view but the idea is also as i mentioned
before
is to bring at the table the voices of
developing countries emerging countries
so that
these are developed thinking taking into
consideration the fact that they might
need to be adapted and
it's already built in you know in the
design that they will be adaptable to
those specific contexts recognizing
where those differences might be
thank you deb
yeah i just had a quick um addition
which was um
another sort of dimension of data's
relationship with like
ai especially modern tools which lean
heavily on machine learning and deep
learning in particular is just
the resource allocation required so
um you know data sets used in modern
machine learning and ai systems are very
very large
and that requires it's very resource
intensive to train a model and deploy a
model
and as a result of that there's very
specific power dynamics that come out of
that
there's a lot of environmental risk but
also it's really hard to control
very very large data sets um and
and things that are sort of only
i guess projects and a culture which we
do have a machine learning of just only
focusing
on collecting as much data as possible
leads to a lot of the mistakes that were
mentioned by the others around
not doing a good job adapting to
specific domains not doing a good job
uh representing the population that it's
going to be deployed on um
and this is you know one of one of the
the
causes of of this is is definitely just
the the sheer volume
of data usually required for these these
systems to work
good point thank you okay so let's turn
to one of the questions from the
audience i'm actually going to pull a
couple together here because
it's um this really interesting thing
we've been talking about the rapid
advancement and innovations and the
technology
and policy and the difference in speed
and so the question of
how can policy be used to advance
innovation to actually support
innovation
to create a policy environment where
there is responsible innovation
is one of the questions that's come in
and whether that touches on data
or international efforts or otherwise
and i wonder patricia can you talk a
little bit about that in terms of
how you see that interplay between
policy and innovation and
the role of the commissioner sure i
i i think there's a um
an important role uh for different forms
of policy deborah talked about agile
forms of policy i'll speak to in a
moment but i i think
at the very basic level there is a
foundation of statutory
policy that's required to set the level
playing field for all competitors
to play fair responsibly and
to spur on innovation so you talked
about for instance
uh c11 c11 is a much needed effort
a federal bill that's been tabled to
modernize the federal act pipita which
is lagging behind in many respects
in terms of its capacity to deal with
um some of the challenges of
artificial intelligence data analytics
that were never
anticipated when it was adopted uh more
than 20 years ago
the um the the
one of the big advantages of pippida was
that it was principles based
from the very outset which allowed it to
survive this long but even
those principles have been overtaken and
is in need of modernization the good
news is c11
is principled based as well there are
provisions in there that deal
specifically
with um automated decision systems so
there's certainly some really important
modernizations there that
will help spur on innovation and provide
predictability
um for for innovators in this space
so that's a good thing there's a
flexible mechanisms for instance of
permitting
consent exemptions for responsible
use and collection of data and along
with that
comes enhanced transparency requirements
stronger accountability mechanisms
the right to an explanation of the
possibility to
um uh also uh spur
uh in stronger enforcement triggering
stronger enforcement mechanisms so all
of that is part of a package
i think from a statutory perspective
that's important to form the base but
along with that what's
important also is that the bill allows
for
other forms of policy more agile
responses such as codes of practice
certification programs where industry
itself
the innovators itself can develop sector
specific guidance
that with the approval of the
commissioner then allow
them as long as they comply with that
code approved or that commissioner
approved code of practice within the
certification program
they are given or provided certain level
of immunity
from downstream uh penalties that could
be imposed
so this is the kind of complementary
forms
of uh of industry-specific
uh compliance mechanisms that i think
are very important in an innovative
space the other forms of self you know
regulatory
mechanisms are the data privacy impact
assessments or pias
or the algorithmic impact assessments uh
in the space of ai that are incredibly
important
and indispensable part of a robust
privacy management program where
again innovators can take matters in
their own hands
in order to you know develop
the baseline that will engender the
trust needed
um to to enable adoption of these
technologies
so i'll i'll leave it at that i can talk
for hours but i think that
uh i think we need both i think we need
statute-based law that forms the
principles the baseline principles and
we need these mechanisms
for compliance initiatives from the
industry
sectors themselves to to complement
those statutes
thank you so much i really do feel like
we could keep talking for
for much more time there's many more uh
questions
uh that i that we all have and lots more
information to share
jacques i want to give you one minute
because there's been a number of
questions that have come in in the q a
about how individuals can get involved
with the global partnership on ai
can you in in sort of 30 seconds or less
just touch on where they should go and
what they should do if they want to
learn more
uh yes sure first web is should go uh
two things they are there's a website
for the gpa so it's gpa.ai and i can
share that on the chat after
and then there's also a web page for the
senior which will be
you know improve over time but that's
the two easy access to get more
information
in terms of how individual can be
involved first
within the terms of reference of the gp
there will be a mechanism where
experts would like to be joining one of
the working groups could actually be
self-nominated there will be a selection
process so not everybody will be
selected but they will
and that process is in the will be
developed over the next couple of months
so
please keep an eye on the gpa website
for more information on that um also as
we support the working groups
through their projects over the coming
years will be and it has been in the
past five months if you call for
proposal for
individuals to come and assist you know
bring their expertise
to the group so again keep an eye on our
website and we also use our partners
website to be built like cfar
to uh to publicize that but that's
another way where
there will be opportunities plus you
know we'll have a interns program within
this
year so that there will be multiple
opportunities for individuals in canada
to join forces and bring their expertise
at the table
fabulous thank you to be continued with
all of you i hope we have an opportunity
soon to reconvene and to pick up on so
many of the topics we started and those
um
and those we will want to continue to
talk about in this
very important area of work thank you
all
merci it's been wonderful to be with you
this afternoon
that concludes our policy panel for
today